[Musique]
une mise en scène de Jean-Louis
bar un cri dans la nuit d'hiver ma
fenêtre est de travers de la ferme de
mon mieux je vois la couleur des cieux
ils sont noirs il y a du vent vent
d'utant vend temp le manteau des
cheminées recommence à frissonner sur la
route j'aperçois un bien étrange
bourgeois donc l'AIJE déjà vu pieds
fourchus et frontcore nus c'est le
diable ou le docteur qui me font mourir
de peur ou bien mon ange gardien je ne
sais plus je le
seraien douce
France cher pays de mon
enfance fa C de tendre ins
soucience je t' gardé dans mon
cœur mon
village au cloché aux maisons
SAG où les enfants de mon
âge ont partager mon
bonœil et je
t'aime et je te donne ce poème
oui je
t'aime la joie ou la
[Musique]
douleur